[Music]
I'm sure that you must have heard of the
word pendulum before do you know what a
simple pendulum is consider an object of
small mass suspended from a fixed end by
the means of a thread wire or a string
this setup is called a pendulum a simple
pendulum is an idealized version of a
physical pendulum in a simple pendulum
the string under consideration is
massless and the object tied to the end
of the string is the point mass
obviously in the macroscopic world there
is no such thing as a massless string
and it's also impossible for an object
to have all the mass concentrated at a
single point however if we take a
sufficiently thin string like a thread
and a very small object heavier than a
string such as a small stone or a
metallic ball we are close to having a
simple pendulum we will assume our setup
to be a simple pendulum anyways the
object attached to one end of the string
is called the Bob of the pendulum
initially the pendulum is at rest the
position of the bob is what we call the
rest position or the mean position now
what will happen if I give this Bob a
little push in either of the directions
you see that it starts moving back and
forth this back and forth motion is
repetitive in nature and hence this
motion of the bob is also called the
oscillatory motion or the cyclic motion
okay so when does it complete one cycle
we say that the bob has covered one
cycle or one oscillation when it moves
from the mean to one extreme point then
to the other extreme and back to the
mean let me repeat from the mean to the
extreme to the opposite extreme and then
back to the main is one oscillation now
obviously due to air resistance this Bob
will eventually come to a halt after
some time however under ideal conditions
the motion will simply repeat itself
forever in equal intervals of time
type of motion is called periodic motion
it means that if a bob takes three
seconds to complete the first cycle then
it will take three seconds to complete
the second the third the tenth or the
fiftieth cycle as well now this constant
time period condition is more accurate
for a simple pendulum where the object
under consideration is small this also
depends on the size of the arc of the
swing as well it means that the bob
should be displaced by a small amount
for the time period to be the same
throughout there is one more interesting
property of a simple pendulum and this
property is what makes them the best
timekeepers this property was first
observed by the Galileo in the 17th
century if I were to tell this property
in simple words then I will frame it
like this please go through it let me
explain
consider three cases where in each case
a pendulum is displaced by a very small
angle believe it or not in all the cases
the time period of the pendulum will be
the same yes this is what this property
tells us let's look at it in slow motion
say all three move to the right first
you can tell from the angle that this
displacement is slightly more than this
one and this displacement is more than
this one after this they all move to the
left and guess what they come back to
the mean positions together at the same
time this tells us that the time it will
take to complete one oscillation will be
the same in all the cases as I told you
this property was first found out by
Galileo Christian Huygens used this
property to invent what's called the
pendulum clock pendulum clocks were very
popular from the 17th century when it
was first made to the 1930s when they
were later replaced by electric clocks
the reason this clock is called so is
because it has a pendulum as its part so
when if the air is
and slightly affects the back-and-forth
motion of a bob the time period will not
be affected the clock will always show
the accurate time
[Music]
you